hi my name is Adam Cohen I'm a professor
in the department's of chemistry and
physics at Harvard today I'm going to
talk to you about a huge unsolved
problem of how to visualize electrical
activity in the brain now take a minute
and put your hand on your head and think
about what you're touching within a
centimeter of your fingers there's a
piece of the most mysterious and poorly
understood matter in the universe here's
a picture of your brain now if we zoom
in by a factor of about 300 we see that
this brain is made up of neurons there's
about a hundred billion of them and
they're connected to each other each by
about ten to the four ten thousand
connections if we zoom in again now by a
factor of ten thousand we see that each
one of these neurons is encased in a
lipid bilayer a little layer of grease
which separates the inside of the cell
from the outside of the cell this
bilayer is an electrical insulator while
the cytoplasm and the extracellular
medium are conductors so you can think
of it a little bit like a parallel plate
capacitor now there are many proteins
that sit in the membrane and these
proteins can pass ions across the
membrane there are charge pumps which
can generate a voltage and there are ion
channels which can relieve this voltage
these channels act a little bit like
resistors except they're nonlinear so if
there's a change in the voltage they can
have big changes in the conductance
which can lead to these electrical
spikes in the membrane voltage which we
call action potentials every action
potential is about a tenth of a volt I
and last about one one thousandth of a
second these are the currency of the
nervous system so every thought and hope
and dream and feeling that we have is
encoded in these patterns of electrical
spikes traveling through the hundred
billion neurons in our brain that's all
there is and so we'd really like to see
these action potentials so that we can
understand what each neuron is doing and
also to look at the global patterns of
activity and the interrelations of the
signals between neurons to understand
how information is being processed
within the nervous system so basically
this is a voltage measurement problem
now traditionally this is measured as
you might measure the voltage in
electrical circuit electrophysiologists
take a glass pipette with a little
electrode in it and jam the pipette into
a cell and then there's another
electrode out in the solution and by
hooking these up to an amplifier they
can measure the voltage difference and
this works nicely but it only measures
one cell at a time it's extremely slow
and laborious to get these electrodes
into the cell and it doesn't give you
the global view of what's going on in a
complex neural circuit here's an
artist's conception of what we'd really
like to do we'd like to just make these
neurons light up when they fire the
problem is you can't see the voltage in
a neuron anymore then you can see the
voltage in a telephone cord when
somebody's having a telephone
conversation we need some contrast agent
to convert membrane voltage into light
now physicists and chemists and
biologists have been working on trying
to invent contrast agents since the late
1960s and this activity has really taken
off in the last few years here are just
a few of the things that people are
working on today these are all from
within the last year or so people are
trying to develop voltage sensitive dyes
so these are organic small molecules
which will intercalate into the membrane
and in some of these dyes illumination
with light generates an electronic
excited state the charge distribution in
the excited state is different than a
charge distribution in the ground state
and so when there's a voltage across the
membrane that voltage perturbs the
relative energy of these two states
which can alter the fluorescent
properties of the dot and so this
provides a means to readout membrane
voltage with fluorescence other people
are trying to put semiconductor nano
crystals in lipid membranes these nano
crystals have quantum mechanical
delocalized electronic states membrane
voltage can again shift the relative
energies of these states and adjust
again the fluorescence properties of
these crystals other people are working
with objects called nitrogen vacancies
in diamonds these are tiny quantum
mechanical defects in diamonds and
people think that if you get a small
enough diamond nano crystal and you
stick it into a membrane the
fluorescence properties of these
nitrogen vacancies will again be
sensitive to
in voltage now I want to emphasize these
are all interesting perspective
technologies but none of these has
solved the problem that I posed at the
beginning yet in all of these
technologies the sensor is sitting in
the membrane and this is because to
measure a voltage difference you need to
be connected both to the inside of the
cell and the outside of the cell other
people including myself are working on
voltage indicators based on fluorescent
transmembrane proteins the idea is to
have a protein which sits in the
membrane and to somehow make its
fluorescence sensitive to the membrane
voltage I'll tell you just a little bit
about one indicator which we've been
developing in my lab the story starts
here this is a picture of the dead sea
there is a micro organism that lives in
the water here that produces a
transmembrane protein called r2 adopts
and 3 this protein absorbs sunlight and
uses that energy to pump a proton a
charge from inside the cell to outside
the cell this generates a membrane
voltage which this creature uses to
power its metabolism so a few years ago
I said to myself I wonder if we can run
this thing in Reverse can we use a
change in membrane voltage to induce a
conformational change in this protein
which will lead to a fluorescent signal
that we can see just like this right and
you see this works in power plunk and so
that's very encouraging after several
years we engineered a protein which had
these attributes and here's a picture of
a human tumor cell where we've
introduced a gene for this protein and
we're using a little patch pipette which
you can't see to induce steps of voltage
between plus and minus 1/10 of a volt
and we're looking at the fluorescence of
the protein so here you can see that as
the voltage goes up the protein gets
bright and as the voltage goes down the
protein gets dim so this is a
genetically encoded fluorescent reporter
a membrane voltage and it turns out to
be quite fast and sensitive but also
very dim which makes it hard to measure
we've now developed technology to take
these proteins and to express them in
neurons in a petri dish so the neurons
become fluorescent and their
fluorescence becomes sensitive to the
voltage in the membrane
we're also expressing another protein in
these cells which renders them sensitive
to blue light this is a light gated ion
channel and targeting a flash of blue
light to the cell body will trigger the
neuron to fire we've developed
computational techniques to infer the
propagation of these electrical impulses
at extremely high time resolution here
I'll show you a movie at a hundred
thousand frames a second of this
optically induced action potential
propagating through a nerve so you can
really see how these signals propagate
through a cell now but this is a neuron
in culture we've taken the rat brain and
we've mooshed it up and we spread out
the neurons in a dish we'd really like
to do this in an intact brain but
neither we nor anybody else on the
planet knows how to do that right now
there are several challenges to this and
I'll tell you about them so one of the
problems we face is that the brain is
not transparent here's a picture of a
mouse brain and you can see it's
scatters light very strongly it's about
the size of my pinky but light scatters
over a distance less than a tenth of a
millimeter and so it's an unsolved
challenge how to visualize what's going
on inside of this chunk of tissue we
need to come up with new kinds of
optical or electrical tricks another
challenge is that in every mouse brain
there's about 75 million neurons to
record from these at a thousand frames a
second which you need to detect action
potentials would lead to a data rate of
about 75 gigabytes a second we don't
know how to store this data let alone
what to do with it if we did have it so
this brings me to another unsolved
challenge which is the interpretation
problem so even if we had the best
technology imaginable for visualizing
electrical activity in the brain how do
we interpret it we'd like to relate the
electrical activity to some statement
about the underlying biology of the
cells what are the ion channels that are
active what's their state of regulation
what's their distribution what's the
metabolic state of the cell what's
happening to its energy supply we all
experience that
we go through our day night cycle the
function of our neurons changes
tremendously whether we're asleep or
awake tired or not tired hungry or not
hungry and those changes are not
mediated by structural changes in the
brain but by changes in presumably the
metabolic state of our neurons and then
finally we'd like to infer from patterns
of activity how the neurons are
connected to each other to figure out
who is calling the shots and who is
controlling them and how they integrate
and process information to illustrate
this here is a movie of some neuron this
was a movie taken in my lab these are
neurons in a dish not in an intact brain
where we'll look at their firing
patterns this is a movie at about 500
frames a second the neurons have been
artificially colored just so you can
tell them apart and we can zoom in on
any one of these cells and look at its
firing pattern and we really don't know
how to interpret these firing patterns
in terms of the ion channels the
energetics and the connectivity of these
cells so there's tremendous scope over
the coming years to combine the efforts
of physicists chemists and biologists to
develop technology which will let us
visualize the activity in this little
chunk of matter which is by between all
of our ears